it's this this film motherless Brooklyn
its I know that it's taking you like
you're there right directing in it as
well and it's taking you 20 years or so
to finish it yeah it did that makes it
sound like I've been working on it for
20 years and I I read the book 20 years
ago I then I then I didn't I didn't work
on adapting it for a few years after
that and then after I wrote it it took a
number of years to get the movie made so
there was these kind of uh it's like
good spaghetti sauce it takes a long
time you know but it depends it depends
everything's different I mean did you
when you were as a cartoonist did you
work always very fast very impulsive ly
or oh you've been googling before you
know yeah well I tried to do the most
fast as possible funny you said good
because Thom Yorke from Radiohead wrote
a beautiful song for this film he he
sent me back a demo just himself on the
piano and and the demo was so good that
we couldn't ever do better than a demo
that that song is it's I think it's
called daily struggles daily battles
daily battle sorry which is which is
something that the film is about too in
a way when it when you when you're an
actor with the degree of success you've
had how much daily battles do you have
yourself I think you know the the thing
about this film is it's it's about it's
about an underdog right it's about a guy
who has a very extreme form of struggle
in the sense that he has Tourette
syndrome and obsessive-compulsive
disorder it's that's in some ways is a
gift and in some ways is gives him
special qualities but but he's also he's
constantly doing battle with himself he
gets in his own way can't even light the
cigarette of a pretty girl because
can't stop wanting to get the sound
better is this also a kind of
perfectionism I mean do you do you
obsess in a way when you're working and
when you work yes I'm I'm I think lots
of actors have a compulsion to mimic
voices mimic I mean half the people in
New York you see walking down the street
muttering to themselves they're actually
actors you know it's they're like yeah
you could do that I do it all the time I
think it's well probably why I chose to
live in New York because you can get
away with it in New York in New York you
can nobody looks twice at someone who's
walking it was talking to themselves in
New York and and now and now especially
if I'm walking down the street muttering
to myself which I do all the time I
think people just look and go oh it's
Edward he's working you know what I mean
like they're they're very familiar with
it by now in my neighborhood but you are
famous for your profoundness the way you
work with a if you if you if you have a
role the way you work with it is very
overtime and you you really go into it
like method acting I guess it's called
or I mean sometimes but sometimes if you
have like if you make a movie with Danny
DeVito death to smoochy about children's
in it it's not really that's not really
a method you have to be no you have to
be style appropriate you know I mean if
you do a certain type of American
History X it's a very different type of
work that's that's a deep immersion you
know where you're inhabiting it and you
want to stay within it to do and we
there are other things that are pure
style if you do it I did a musical with
Woody Allen if you if you brought the
same approach to it that you brought to
American history acts he'd fire you in
five minutes
like you have to be malleable you have
to have you know you have to you have to
bring a capacity to work within
different styles you mentioned the
American History X do you do you do you
still have that body
I never really did I never was as big as
people thought we we actually we cast
people who were a lot smaller than me
all around me because I'm I mean I weigh
150 whale you 63 kilos you know it's
like I'm not I'm not a big I'm not a big
person and I didn't get that big I got
big for me but we I'm not joking we cast
people all around me who were much
smaller than me because the camera can't
tell you you you turned 50 recently yeah
I I read I read that and that was only
three exact how do you feel it well it
felt it felt good in a way yeah until I
read that you were 50 I made you feel
older extremely yeah so that's really
but it must have been tough for you as
well I feel like I'm in better shape at
this age than my dad was so I I was
trying to figure out like was my dad in
about the shape I'm in when he was 37 so
I think 50 is the new 37 you know like
I've done a discounting you wrote about
the making of the film there was a
dramatic fire what was it that happened
we were filming in a building and a fire
started our crew was incredibly
professional everybody got out but
unfortunately they're you know in fight
in fighting the fire in the whole
building in New York firefighter died
which was very tragic yeah how did that
affect you in the work of the film some
of the firefighters in his in his own
battalion is you know the own unit were
back at work like two days later we were
with to some of them and speaking with
some of them and some of them said to us
like do your work make a great you know
make a great film like that's that's
every we're all going back to work and
and you have and and I and I did and I
felt like if they were able to go back
to work we ought to be able to go back
to work alright when you actually see it
something like a fire going on and and
you see people going into it to get
other people out of it it's
mind-boggling
it's an incredibly emotional thing to
see to see people who are who whose work
is to care for other people it's that
it's like and you go that's true heroism
that is like truly it's heroism is not
power it's not money it's not like power
over other people it's it's people who
actually go put themselves out to help
other people I wanted you two to give us
as a take away three scenes three scenes
that people can go online and find them
three scenes that inspired you as an
actor not with yourself though none of
mine Rihanna less three scenes should
we'll look for it I think if you look at
taxi driver in taxi driver the famous
scene where he's sort of losing his mind
and confronting himself imagining
himself having a violent confrontation
with someone and then and in rate in
Raging Bull the opening scene in Raging
Bull when he's when he's practicing his
monologue in the mirror those to me were
very i they had a big impact on me
because they were so in a way it's like
an actor it's like a person looking at
themselves and and you can see into the
person's psychology by the way their
imagination is working they're not even
interacting with someone else there's an
arrow and the mirror that's yeah the
narrows mirror scenes I think taxi
driver Raging Bull those are those I
watched those many many dozens of times
because I thought they were incredibly
intense and and deep that's to you well
I think pushing to the feminine I think
like I think mayor I've watched the
things Meryl Streep
I could name like a dozen things that
Meryl Streep has done in films that I
have been like flattened by
because she makes she makes choices that
if you said to an actor in an acting
class do this 1,000 of them would do it
the same way and she does it at a right
angle I've always been really astonished
by her instinct for the the
non-intuitive thing but there's a moment
there's a moment in the film French
Lieutenant's woman with Jeremy Irons
where it's toward the end of the film
and if you look at it she's he's been
looking for her she's in a nursery and
he confronts her and he he goes to leave
and she tries to stop him and he throws
her he pushes her and she falls down
this small flight of stairs and she she
lands so hard that he comes running in
and she does you expect it's very
melodramatic and then suddenly she just
laughs she kind of laughs at the at the
absurdity of the whole situation
and it and the whole thing just
decompresses like all the anger and all
the drama
it just decompresses and it's one of
those things that you watch and you just
go what would make her do that like why
would she do that and so I would watched
it over and over again but it's really
fascinating if you watch it you could
watch it closely you can see that she
really hits her head she she hits her
head on the floor and Jeremy Irons goes
running down to her completely broken
out of the scene and he starts to ask
her if she's okay and she covers his
mouth she puts her hand on his mouth
like to say don't don't drool Aziz and
she covers his mouth and when he
realizes that she's still going he
covers his own face like this to stop
from smiling and she does this laugh and
goes on and I asked her about it I said
is anybody ever and she said no she said
that is exactly what happened I hit my
head and Baba it's really worth watching
when things like that happen and people
and someone's able to to use it and lean
into it that's like that's sort of the
the best of it but she she's done that
like a million times you know I think
she's wondering well you have to Edward
Norton thank you so much for you
thank you very much hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you